the following is a special color
telecast of the 39th annual awards of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences
stay tuned for felony Squad Peyton Place
Rat Patrol and iron horse which will
immediately follow this special program
one of the highlights of Academy Award
night each year for motion picture fans
across the country and especially for
those here at Santa Monica Civic
Auditorium is the arrival of the
glamorous celebrity a star of great
stature mr. Jimmy Stewart accompanied by
his twin daughters one of Hollywood's
most durable leading men mr. Glenn Ford
and here's Patricia Neal former Oscar
winner for her performance in the hug
handsome Rock Hudson
ever glamorous Ginger Rogers
Robert Mitchum
I
and with a Mary Poppins umbrella Dick
Van Dyke
this year's nominee a new PA for a man
and a woman she's beautiful
Raquel Welch gold pajamas
you
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences mr. Arthur freed
for the 39th time we're gathered to
honor films filmmakers and film players
for what we in the American motion
picture arts and sciences adjudged the
finest no matter what their national
origin because of the impact of film on
all societies the presentation of our
Oscars has become an annual beacon that
attracts the attention of the world to
this moment of the epical history we're
grateful the moviegoers share our
interest in the accomplishments of each
passing year and the Academy is
therefore pleased to extend a warm
welcome to you all
here again is the one man who knows what
the Morrow's headlines will announce for
he is the guardian of the winning names
mr. bill Miller
certification that the auditors have
tabulated the ballots in secret and the
results are in these envelopes
Thank You Belle now it is time to place
these ceremonies in the hands of its
master
a man equally at home in motion pictures
television and in the hearts of us all
America's comic conscious mr. Bob Hope
thank you very much good evening ladies
and gentlemen welcome to the on again
off again and again not again
39th annual Academy Awards this is the
big night what tension what drama
what suspense and that was just deciding
whether the show was going on or not
actually we just got the word about a
half hour ago and I hope the
teleprompter knows the strike is over
this could be the first to our
commercially sponsored pause anyway
we're happy the strike is over the
incrimination suspicious and anger are
all behind us now the real fighting
begins the strike had one disaster
Johnny Carson quit and everyone was very
sympathetic Joey Bishop flew into New
York just to help him pack strike took a
long time to settle because there was
nobody from the network's for the Union
to talk to they were all doing newscasts
it's disconcerting to haggle with a
network vice-president who's wearing
makeup and the network's were hiring
anybody that could talk
NBC traded the peacock for a parakeet
I was really caught in the middle being
both the star of movies and the star of
television instead of dinner tonight I
just smoked a banana farce I could never
take the chance of crossing an after
picket line and losing my actors card
it's the only proof I've got so once
again the fantastic facilities of
television and the great artistry the
motion picture industry are blended so
you and your home can turn to your
neighbor and say they cut rat patrol for
this I wish you could see this wonderful
glamorous audience it's a sea of
expensive gowns fabulous jewels
luxurious minks and the sheared beavers
who paid for the expensive gowns
this is the biggest night of the year
for the movie industry it must be it
says so in TV god this is the night
devoted to one man Oscar or as he's
known around my house the fugitive
tonight
I feel like the Gaul at a NATO
conference but tonight we salute
Hollywood doors it's better known this
year the birthplace of politicians
pretty soon we're going to meet another
category Best Performance by a
government
I'm happy to be your MC again this year
and if you're wondering why they chose
me they wanted someone who was charming
or bein witty and completely uninvolved
I want to tell you this year I'm so far
out of the running I'm even jealous of
the losers 39 years and still no
recognition of my acting by the time I
get an Oscar Huntley will be speaking to
Brinkley what a month I not only didn't
get nominated but I got a splinter from
my picket sign and how do you like some
of the actors that were nominated Alan
Arkin Michael Caine George Segal they
hadn't been in the business long enough
to make channel 13
but what right have I to complain when
the Academy missed such obvious choices
as ex-governor wallets for Best
Performance in a supporting role Senator
Robert Kennedy producer and vice
president Hubert Humphrey for Best
Costume in color he had caught a trip
for a while he thought he had Nixon's
olá gathered in this auditorium tonight
of the great actors and actresses
producers directors and writers were
responsible for making pictures what
they are today for adults only this is
the night of nights the one night in the
year when we forgive each other our
trespasses and band together to beat the
English backstage there whispering the
russians had come in the Russians are
coming
but the British are already here where
is that Paul Revere when you need it no
I understand that Buddhist contingent
had a little trouble getting in here
tonight George Raft is one of the ushers
and some fine new acting talent emerge
this year Anouk aimée David Hemmings
candy Bergen Sam your tea Adam Clayton
caller a lot of good pictures were
nominated alpha is a documentary which
proves that everything in England
doesn't stop for tea I was about a
ruthless charming handsome Rotter who is
absolutely irresistible to women
I thought Michael Caine was wonderful as
me and the Russians are coming
introduced to the screen that brilliant
hilariously funny young comedian whose
name I can't for the life of me remember
know Alan Arkin was wonderful he was the
funniest Russian since Gromyko there are
some grim things and a man for all
seasons Paul Scofield is a capitated for
refusing to play ball with a king Walter
O'Malley loved he'd like to remake it
with Sandy Koufax
when Robert Wise was casting the sand
pebbles he looked over the list of
Chinese actors and said I'll take ten
from colony six from column B and give
Billy Wilder the fortune cookie and our
bottle is and Richard there's an unusual
couple they're both expecting
if only one of them wins I hope it's her
he's already got a crazy footballer and
I'm sure you all saw Virginia Woolf that
wonderful sequel to Bambi I haven't
heard language like that since the MGM
proxy fight anyway we certainly learned
a lot from pictures this year Virginia
Woolf was really a college education
alfie was a master's degree and Georgia
girl was certainly head of the liberal
arts department next time I see mr.
clean I'm going to punch him right in
the mind so let's get on with his
farcical charade of vulgar egotism and
pomposity
that's nice thing about being a loser
you can say what you want so on with a
feud of Santa Monica tonight in the
tradition of the Montagues and the
Capulets two great theatrical families
clash head-on the maw and Paul Burton
clan of Beverly Hills and Mike Redbridge
sidesaddle riders from eastern
Piccadilly so it's time to announce it
our home for our first little orphan
oscar here's a new star in the celluloid
sky a heavenly body that made the
fantastic voyage from small parts to
leading roles her name is Raquel Welch
and she's here to help that engaging
young lady man Dean Jones present our
first Oscar
Raquelle
will you begin please secondly we're
honored to present the award for the
best achievement in sound the
nominations are gambit Universal City
Studios sound department Grand Prix
metro-goldwyn-mayer studio sound
Department Hawaii Samuel Goldwyn studio
sound department the sand pebbles 20th
Century Fox studio sound department who
is Afraid of Virginia Woolf Warner
Brothers Studio sound department
I tell you um Raquel I'll open the
envelope and you read the winner all
right my eyes are busy the winner is
Metro golden man studio sound department
for Grand Prix
on behalf of metro-goldwyn-mayer studios
psalm department is sound director
Franklin Milton I wish to thank the
Academy on behalf of many people of our
sound Department boos there's technical
talents and creative ability have made
this possible thank you very much